european union leaders have committed to
a tougher clamp down on tax evasion and
fraud amid a growing public outcry over
doubtful practices that cost the EU
around 1 trillion euros each year at the
summit in Brussels the leaders set an
end of June deadline for new measures to
crack down on fraud on value-added tax
the speed of negotiations on tougher
savings tax agreements with Switzerland
Liechtenstein Monaco and Dora and San
Marino will be accelerated at the same
time the leaders unanimously committed
to complete by the end of the year the e
u--'s revised savings directive which
has proved a thorny dossier until now
they also agreed to push internationally
for automatic information sharing on a
wide range of taxable income an end of
year deadlines were set on taxation in
the business sector like the issue of
profit shares and aggressive tax
planning by major companies which made
headlines in recent days there's a
strong political world by the leaders
not only the Europeans but also on a
global level to go forward in attacking
tax fraud and tax evasion it is a new
situation it is unprecedented the crisis
unprecedented and the awareness on
tackling this issue is unprecedented
also high on the leaders agenda was
energy and ways to tap into sustainable
and affordable supplies the talks
focused on energy efficiency and how to
turn the e use 27 energy markets into
one energy market by next year with no
nation left unconnected by 2015 the
leaders also discussed ways to diversify
energy sources to ensure that no EU
nation has only one supplier or one
supply route they also pledged to
consult with the EU partners before
taking any action on energy that might
have a major impact on their neighbors